we see one form of champion going down
here ash rita was able to take down
another former champ and we weren't
paying too much attention to your game
as sharitha as there's other games that
were afoot but now that i had a chance
to look at it
wow diamonds in my eyeballs yasser go to
move 18 on your board and let us enjoy
the evisceration that ashrita put on
well move 18 is the move bishop e7 after
rook b3 bishop e7 right here and as rita
what an attack you got the position was
fairly nondescript but suddenly she just
gave you some chances with this move at
5.
um yeah i was actually surprised by her
opening choice with the c takes d4 here
in the steinitz variation i just thought
i think
i was actually in my preparation till
queen h4 check and then i couldn't
really remember it but i think after
bishop f2 it felt easy for me to play
especially with her king in the middle
of the board
um
and after queen d8 castle i thought you
know she queens i thought maybe rook c8
instead of queen seed but she started i
think here she spent like 40 minutes on
the clock
um and so i felt like she thought it was
an uncomfortable position for her and so
after queen c8 rook b3 bishop e7 i
thought i had to go for this f5 move
just go for the attack sure
and i didn't really see like
i thought her queen c4 was good and then
i wasn't entirely sure if rookie one was
correct or not but i thought rookie won
and if she castles um f6
g takes f6 and queen h6 and then i'm
threatening my d5 and rook g3 and i
think
she's in trouble there
nasty no question about that that looks
like a really nice you're all set up
with the rover so
she played bishop c6 to avoid castling
the engine says that that's a blunder
bishop b4 was best
and now here you come
yeah i thought uh when she played bishop
c6 and back to d7 she allowed me to
regroup my pieces a little bit and
knight d4
and rook c8 and then i thought you know
maybe she's threatening bishop b4 here
and so i was like just stop everything
with a3 um
and then no counter chances in here e6
fe 6 knight e6 i saw this like a couple
moves ahead she took on e6 rookie six
and king f7
and here i think rookie six rookie seven
is just winning king e7 queen g5
i thought
i thought her best move was king d6
instead of king e6
because if i go king d6 and then if i
try
like queen g7 with the idea queen f6 and
rex c3 i thought i saw she had queen b3
here
c takes b6 oh
that's a tricky one easy to miss
and so after king d6 but the engine zoo
give queen h6 check after queen takes b3
guarding the c1 square nice intermezzo
oh
yeah and i saw this afternoon i was like
okay you know queen g5 is winning and
then but she played king e6 instantly
which surprised me which just allowed
rookie three
king d6 queenie seven and rookie six
and she's getting mated i believe yes
wow
convincing
oh beat down that was like very
absolutely beat down
ashrita you were doing quite well in
this event but a hiccup here and there
kind of dampened your opportunities how
are you feeling about the tournament
after this round i'm really glad i could
get a win especially like this um i had
a rough three days i'd say i think two
games i should have lost that i lost and
then one game that you know i was losing
and then almost had a draw it had five
moves till then that was very painful
but chess is hard so chess is hard but
this one is one to smile about beating a
former champ in this style we'll let you
rest for the last round thank you
well